وصل المشجعوننا الى الدوحه من كرواتيا
والاكوادور والمكسيك وغيرها من 32 بلد
مشاركا في المونديال يلونون شوارع الدوحه
التي كانت فارغه حتى وقت قريب
مره في العمر ثم ان قطر مختلف
من
جميع الناس
هذا البلد الصغير ينتظر اكثر من مليون
مشجع استقباله شعوب العالم امر رائع نشعر
بانها الامم المتحده اعداد المشجعين
الفرنسيين محدوده حتى الان بعضهم ترددا
كثيرا قبل المجيد
ولكن لا يجب التستر عما يدور خلف ذلك
على بيع جميع التذاكر المباريات
رهان سهل التحقيق تذاكر مباريات الارجنتين
باتت نادره جدا
سعيد جدا شراء تذاكر مباريات الارجنتين
صعبه للغايه يريد الجميع مشاهده ميسي
لكنها اداره الفيفا اعلنت انها ستطرح بعض
التذاكر الاضافيه للمباراه الثانيه